so jen saki so white house can you just
answer me a simple question
what policies have you
used with regard to the ukraine conflict
what policies have you put in place that
have worked
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions are
going to take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked
what the president has done is he has
built a global coalition
to stand up in the face of president
putin and president putin's aggression
and invasion of ukraine what he has done
is he has rallied the world our eu
european partners even at cost to them
in some capacities to put in place uh
significant sanctions historic sanctions
that would have a a a enormous impact on
the russian financial sector
it is president putin's choice to go to
war and invade ukraine that is what he
has done
so nothing you got nothing okay
you you knew that jan saki had nothing
the moment that peter ducey finished
asking the question and she said hey
what wait hold on what worked what do
you mean what worked like she's stalling
like kids do in class you know seventh
grade english class hey johnny what what
happened in chapter three
uh chapter three
do you want me to answer the question
about you yes that's what i asked you
chapter three huh um
well let me get let me give you a little
lesson about literature that's what
she's saying let me give you a little
lesson about diplomacy no i don't need a
lesson about diplomacy i don't need
international relations 101 just
cite the policy that's worked
well
um
well hey forget about the policies that
we've already tried that didn't work uh
we're going to put some sanctions on
russia
oh oh you're going to put sanctions on
russia the thing that trump did that
then biden took away
but okay what kind of sanctions because
trump put sanctions on russian energy
trump stopped the
nordstrom 2 pipeline which is
if any
specific
individual event
is at the heart of this war right now
between russia and ukraine it would be
this pipeline because the minute that
vladimir putin gets to the green light
on his pipeline he gets to invade
ukraine because he doesn't need to rely
on ukraine to ship his oil from russia
to europe
so what about that oh right joe biden
gave the green light to the pipeline
which was essentially rolling out the
red carpet for vladimir putin to invade
ukraine what are you doing now oh you're
putting sanctions on russia except
you're not sanctioning the russian
energy industry which is the only thing
that matters in russia how did you
choose which internet service provider
to use the sad thing is most of us have
very little choice because isps operate
like monopolies in the regions they
serve that's why you got to check out
expressvpn expressvpn is a fabulous way
to protect your data from isps who want
to look at all of your data i protect
all of my devices with expressvpn it's a
simple app for your computer or
smartphone it encrypts all your network
data and tunnels it through a secure vpn
server so that your isp cannot see any
of your activity just think about how
much of your life is on the internet
think about all those websites you go to
you know on the incognito window that's
not so incognito you know websites that
could get you in a lot of trouble if
people found out about it talk about
dailywire.com and other right-wing
websites they can get you into a lot of
trouble all right so use expressvpn
great way to hide your activity online
from your isp download the app
put it on your phone on your computer
simple one button go to expressvpn.com
michael knowles show to get three extra
months for free that this news had
started to break on friday
okay we're gonna have sanctions on all
the other
industries in russia russian
haberdashers are going to be in trouble
the people who make those stacking dolls
in russia oh boy they're going to have a
bad christmas they're going to have
trouble heating their homes but they're
not going to have too much trouble
because the russian oil industry is
going to be just fine
the russian gas industry is going to be
just fine nothing they've done nothing
that has worked and i was trying to
figure out why
why we know that the bidens are in the
pocket of ukraine let's
not forget speaking of the energy
industry joe biden's son hunter had a
no-show job in ukraine because ukraine
is also a corrupt oligarchy just like
russia and and he had this no-show job
where he was being paid hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars to do
absolutely nothing for the expertise in
ukrainian oil that he obviously does not
possess
so why by the biden family has
some interest in ukraine
why
why do they seem to be so incoherent in
their policy because they don't
have any direction they didn't think
this war was pot the liberal
establishment did not believe this war
would really happen
it it breaks their view of the world
that russia would invade another country
and so they don't know what to do when
it happens and they go one way and they
go the other and they keep vacillating
back and forth and they're what they're
really trying to do is just pretend that
it's not happening
but it is happening
and it's happening because of specific
policies and incentives you left in
place i'm so glad you liked that clip
you know by the way if you want to watch
me compete against the big boss himself
ben shapiro we've got a new episode of
face off
famous dead guys edition
listen i've gone up against dave rubin
i've gone up against matt walsh now i'm
going up against ben himself the results
i don't want to spoil anything the
results might surprise you go check out
that episode go subscribe to the michael
knowles show at apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]